ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. HURRY ILLA
POWER QUE HAN BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BURNER **** BATH BONTA
BRO BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY DEEP
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH. OWN TING VOEPEL
WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY OSHA FROM NEXT.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION. AS WE IN THE SECOND
WEEK OF JANUARY I'D LIKE TO
SHARE THE NEW YEAR'S REST.
REFLECTION OF THE DALAI LAMA.
HIS HOLINESS WISHED US ALL A
HAPPY NEW YEAR THEN HE ADDED. A
NEW YEAR IS LIKE A BLANK BOOK.
THE PAN IS IN YOUR HANDS IT IS
YOUR CHANCE TO RIDE A BEAUTIFUL
STORY FOR YOURSELF. AS WE IN
THE SECOND WEEK OF THE NEW YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY. LET US GIVE
THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT BEAUTIFUL
STORY ABOUT OURSELVES WE WOULD
LIKE TO LOOK BACK ON WHEN THE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY COMES TO A
CLOSE. LET'S TRY TO WRITE A
STORY WE WOULD BE HONORED TO
SHARE. NUMBER ONE THE NUMBER
TWO WITH KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND WORDS. THANK YOU
REVEREND WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITOR TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS AS SHE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISS WICKS PLEASE PLACE
YOUR RIGHT HAND OVER YOUR
HEART. READY BEGIN. I PLEDGE. A.
SAN. THANK YOU YOU MAY BE
SEATED. READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY NOVEMBER
TWELFTH 2019% TO THE PROVISIONS
OF JOINT RULE THIRTY NINE THE
FALLING IT'S ONLY JOURNAL FOR
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION WAS PRINTED
WHILE THE FAMILY WAS AN INTERIM
RATE STUDY RECESS. THE BALLING
COMMUNICATION WAS PRESENTED BY
THE ASSISTANT CHIEF CLERK. IN
ORDERED PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
HERE IS LATEST DESIGNER
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION A REFERENCE TO
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE. THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS JIM COOPER AND
MEGAN DALLY FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES. I AM MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI AND
WALDRON TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
CHOI MEDINA PETRIE-NORRIS AND
WEBER TO SPEAK ON IN GERMANY
MEMORY TODAY. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX AND WITHDRAWAL
AB THREE TWENTY THREE DAILY
FROM THE BUDGET COMMITTEE IN
ORDER THE BILL BACK TO THE
THIRD THIRD READING FILE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO STRIKE ITEM WENT
NUMBER ONE EIGHTEEN A. B. SEVEN
FOURTEEN FROM THE FILE. WITHOUT
A CHEN AGAIN SUCH A WITH YOUR-
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
TO ALLOW THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
TO NOTICE A BEFORE NINETY FIVE
MURATSUCHI. ON FRIDAY JANUARY
SEVENTEENTH UPON A GERMAN OF
SESSION PENDING REFERRAL FROM
FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION AGAIN SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER
. MEMBERS. WE
HAVE VERY SPECIAL GUEST WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER TODAY.
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
STONE. OUR QUE HAN BURNER ****
BATH KANSEN CHU. QUIRK AND
ROBERT RIVAS THE ASSEMBLY
WELCOMES PARTICIPANTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA INVENTION CONVENTION
FOR TWENTY TWENTY THEY ARE K.
THROUGH EIGHTH GRADE STUDENTS
THE CONVENTION IS AN AFFILIATE
OF THE HENRY FORD INVENTION
CONVENTION WORLDWIDE PROGRAM TO
FOSTER DEVELOPMENT IN STEM
RELATED FIELDS THEY ARE SEATED
IN THE GALLERY AND THEY WILL BE
SET UP IN A ROOM THREE
SEVENTEEN. FROM TWO TO FOUR PM
TODAY IF YOU'D LIKE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THEIR INVENTIONS PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM TO
THE ASSEMBLY
. MEMBERS. MEMBERS
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
MISS WALDRON. FROM THE REAR THE
CHAMBER AT MY DESK MISS WALDRON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
TODAY WE ARE JOINED BY TWO VERY
SPECIAL PEOPLE FROM MY DISTRICT
FIRE CHIEF STEVEN ABIT. FROM
THE NORTH COUNTY FIRE
PROTECTION DISTRICT AND HIS
WIFE ALISON. STEVE IS CURRENTLY
SERVING HIS SECOND TERM ON THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR THE FALL
BURKE HEALTHCARE DISTRICT AND
IS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE
ROTARY CLUB OF FALL FOR. THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA SEVENTY
FIFTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT ARE
IMMENSELY GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK
THE CHIEF ABBOTT DOES TO KEEP
THEM SAFE EVERY DAY MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING
FIRE CHIEF ABBOTT AND HIS WIFE
ALISON TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
.
AND MISS WALDRON YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. IT IS
TRULY THE END OF AN ERA FOR
LEGISLATIVE REPUBLICANS. AS THE
NORA RAMIREZ ONE OF OUR LONGEST
SERVING STAFFERS. HAS DECIDED
TO CALL IT A CAREER. THE NOR
BEGAN HER THIRTY ONE YEARS
UNDER THE DOME AS A
RECEPTIONIST FOR ASSEMBLY WOMAN
SUNNY MOTION AIR. SHE WENT ON
TO BECOME A SCHEDULER
LEGISLATIVE AIDE EDUCATION
CONSULTANT CAPITAL DIRECTOR
LEGISLATIVE LAYS ON. AND BUDGET
MANAGER TO NORA SERVE THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THREE SENATORS
AND A LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR. FOR
THE PAST TEN YEARS THE NOR HAS
SERVED AS OFFICE MANAGER IN THE
ASSEMBLY REPUBLICAN OFFICE OF
POLICY A BUDGET. IN THIS
CAPACITY TO NOR SUPERVISE AND
TRAIN CAUCUS STAFF MAINTAINED
AND ARCHIVED RECORDS MANAGE
OFFICE CALENDARS AND PROVIDED
VITAL SUPPORT TO CAUCUS
CONSULTANTS. IN RETIREMENT TO
NORA LOOKS FORWARD TO SPENDING
MORE TIME WITH HER HUSBAND CARE
MALL RAMIREZ HER DAUGHTER'S
ALEJANDRO AND BRENDA AND HER
EXTENDED FAMILY TO NORA THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE THIRTY
ONE YEARS OF DEDICATED SERVICE.
WE WISH YOU ALL THE BEST IN
YOUR FUTURE ENDEAVORS MEMBERS
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
TO NORA RAMIREZ
. MEMBERS WE ARE
NOW MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. GOVERNOR'S VETO
SHALL BE CONTINUED. ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS ONE
NINETEEN THROUGH ONE TWENTY
THREE ARE TO BE CONTINUED WE
ARE MOVING TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. FILE ITEMS ONE TWENTY
FOUR THROUGH ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PASS AND RETAIN. THAT BRINGS US
TO FILE ITEM. ONE TWENTY NINE
AC ARE. ONE FORTY. I. MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE KEEP THE VOLUME
LEVEL MANAGEABLE WE HAVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY MR STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED PART OF ME. THE
CLERK READ THE RESOLUTION
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT REOLUTION
ONE FORTY BY SOMETHING MEMBER
MARK STONE AND OTHERS RELATIVE
TO POSITIVE PARENTING AWARENESS
MONTH MR STONE YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS WE HAVE PUT A GREAT
DEAL OF FOCUS WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. THIS YEAR LAST
YEAR ON THE EARLIEST IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE THE YOUNGEST IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND THAT IS
THOSE WHO ARE ZERO TO FIVE AND
FOCUSING ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION ON WORKING ON EARLY
DEVELOPMENT AND IN TRYING TO
SHIFT THE FOCUS TO THOSE WHO
NEED US THE MOST AND
ESPECIALLY. FROM A- BUT IN THAT
CONVERSATION BUT FORGET HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO HELP THE
PARENTS OUT AS WELL. WE CANNOT
HEAL THE CHILD IF WE CANNOT
HEAL THE FAMILY. AND THAT IS
WHERE POSITIVE PARENTING COMES
IN THERE ARE NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS. IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE TRYING TO HELP. YOUNG
PARENTS ESPECIALLY BUT OTHER
PARENTS WHO ARE INTERESTED. TO
BECOME BETTER PARENTS AND LEARN
HOW TO BE THE PARENTS THAT
PERHAPS THEIR PARENTS WORK
BECAUSE A LOT OF THESE PROBLEMS
OF POVERTY. AND ADVERSE
EXPERIENCES. ARE GENERATIONAL
AD ARE CYCLIC. SO WHAT
POSITIVE PARENTING MONTH IS
INTENDED TO DO IS TO RAISE
AWARENESS AND HOW THE
CONVERSATIONS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ABOUT THE BENEFITS
OF THESE PROGRAMS THEY GIVE
TOOLS TO PARENTS. TO BECOME
BETTER PARENTS. SOME PARENTS
WHO HAD WERE NOT HELD THIS
CHILDREN DON'T KNOW THAT
SOMETIMES THE BEST THING THEY
CAN DO IS TO HOLD THEIR CHILD
READ TO THEIR CHILD. PROVIDE
THAT BENEFIT POSITIVE PARENTING
MONTH IS. TO BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT THE PROGRAMS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND TO HOPEFULLY BE
ABLE TO FOSTER THESE PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM. AND MAKE
SURE THAT ALL PARENTS HAVE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND HAVE THE
BEST OPPORTUNITY POSSIBLE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR CHILDREN AND
LEARN HOW TO BE STRONG PARENTS
WITHOUT. MISTER SPEAKER AFTER
THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR CALL
AUTHORS. AND THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT WITH A C. R. ONE
FORTY. THANK YOU MISTER DOWN
MISTER GRAY. YOUR RECORD LAST
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE AS A PROUD
JOIN AUTHOR OF ACR ONE FORTY.
AND ALSO AS A PROUD JOINT
PARENT. OF TWO WONDERFUL
CHILDREN WITH MY WIFE TAMMY.
RAISING CHILDREN COULD BE AS
YOU ALL KNOW THAT OUR PARENTS
ONE OF THE MOST REWARDING
THINGS. ANYONE CAN EVER
EXPERIENCE BUT AS A PARENT YOU
ALSO KNOW. THEY CAN BE ONE OF
THE MOST STRESSFUL THINGS A
PERSON CAN EXPERIENCE. BUT FOR
REASONS OF APPARENT WORRYING
ABOUT WHETHER THEY'RE MAKING
THE RIGHT CHOICES. AND THE AND-
MAKING- THE- THE RIGHT OR
SENDING THE RIGHT DIRECTION FOR
THEIR CHILDREN. SO THIS
RESOLUTION IT ENCOURAGES
FAMILIES TO IMPLEMENT PROVEN
POSITIVE PARENTING STRATEGIES.
AND HIGHLIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITIES AS
WAS MENTIONED- THAT CAN PROVIDE
THE SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED
POSITIVE PARENTING HOPES TO
GIVE CHILDREN. THE SKILLS THAT
THEY NEED TO BE COMFORTABLE
WITH THEIR EMOTIONS CONFIDENT
IN THEIR ABILITIES. I AM
PREPARED TO BE OVERCOME ORDERS
WILL PREPARE TO OVERCOME ANY OF
LIFE'S ADVERSITIES THAT THEY
MAY FACE. SO BUYING RIGID AND-
NOT WHAT THE PARENTS BUT ALSO
THOSE THAT OUR GRANDPARENTS OR
CARE GIVERS. FOSTER PARENTS
EVEN FAMILY MEMBERS TO CARE FOR
A CHILD TO FOCUS ON POSITIVE
POINTS TO BE HIT AND DON'T THE
RELATIONSHIP. ON COMMUNICATION
TO RESPECT WE CAN STRENGTHEN
FAMILIES BONDS AS WELL RED. THE
END OF THE RUN I RISE TODAY IN
KILEY REQUEST THAT YOU SUPPORT
A C. R. ONE FORTY. THANK YOU
MISTER GRAYSON SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION MR
STONE HAS ASKED THAT THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
WITH THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. AS
CO AUTHORS ON ACR ONE FORTY.
WELL I. THE CLERK WELL CLOSER
ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY NINE CO
AUTHORS ADDED TO THE RESOLUTION
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MEAN TAKE
A VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
AND MR STONE BACK TO YOU FOR
YOUR SPECIAL GUESTS
INTRODUCTION RELATIVE TO THE
RESOLUTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MEMBERS IN THE
GALLERY AROUND US OR A NUMBER.
OF MEMBERS OF THE COALITION OF
FIRST FIVE ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING
POSITIVE PARENTING PROGRAMS IN
THEIR OLD PHONE COMMUNITY
THEY'RE HERE TODAY TO TALK TO
LEGISLATORS ABOUT THE BENEFITS
OF POSITIVE PARENTING AND I
THINK LOOK OVER OUR SHOULDERS
TO MAKE WE ACTUALLY PASSED THAT
RESOLUTION SO. LET'S GIVE THEM
A CALL A HOBBY ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY. ACR ONE FORTY TWO
SEPARATE ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHOI AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO CREATE AMERICAN
DAY. DOCTOR CHOI ON THE
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU SPEAKER
AND THE MEMBERS. AS I'VE DONE A
ANNUALLY IT IS ON MY HONOR TO
PRESENT TO YOU TODAY IS G. R.
ONE FORTY TWO WHICH WOULD
RECOGNIZE THE JANUARY
THIRTEENTH A TOOL FIVE **** AS
A KOREAN AMERICAN DAY. THIS IS
SO TO COMMEMORATE THE OF ONE
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN TH
ANNIVERSARY OF OUR KOREAN
IMMIGRATION TO AMERICA. NOT
ONLY IN CALIFORNIA ABOUT THE
OUT THE ROUTE SO. UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA IN NINETEEN OH
THREE. THE FIRST OF ONE HUNDRED
TWO KOREAN IMMIGRANTS- CAME TO
THE UNITED STATES OF FROM KOREA
TO WORK ON THE SUGAR
PLANTATIONS SO IN HOW WHY. I
SAW LANDED IN HAWAII TO FIRST
TIME WHEN I ARRIVED IN THE U.
S. IN. NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT TO
FIFTY TWO YES AGO BELIEVE IT OR
NOT. AS OF A TWO THOUSAND TEN
MORE THAN ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION. PAUL LIVING IN THE
UNITED STATES I HAVE KOREAN
ANCESTRY. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BEING HOME TO LARGEST A
POPULATION OF KOREAN AMERICANS
IT IS ONLY FITTING THAT THE WAY
YOUR RECOGNIZE THAT THIS PART
OF OUR STATE SO COMMUNITY. SO
IT IS SO ON THIS DAY THAT
THOUGH WE COMMEMORATE THE
ARRIVAL OF THE FIRST TO ONE
HUNDRED TOOL BRAVE THE SOLDIERS
THAT CAME TO THE UNITED STATES-
AND THE CELEBRATE THE ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION HORROR HE- TODAY.
WITH THAT I ASK YOU FOR YOUR
AYE BOLT ON THIS SO RESOLUTION
WONDER. ONE HUNDRED FORTY TWO
AND ON ALSO SPEAKER MAY I ASK
FOCAL OFFICE JORDAN. ARE ON
THIS RESOLUTION. THANK YOU
DOCTOR CHOI MISS FRIEDMAN. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AC
ARE A HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO.
AND I RISE TODAY NOT ONLY. FOR
THE RECOGNITION OF THE-
NUMEROUS CREATE AMERICANS THAT
RESIDED MY DISTRICT BUT ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS. AND THE REASON
IS BECAUSE AS I WORK WITH THE
KOREAN COMMUNITY OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS. I'VE BECOME VERY
AWARE OF THEIR WORK ON WOMEN'S
ISSUES AND IN PARTICULAR. OUGHT
TO OF RECOGNIZING THE COMFORT
WOMEN WHO ARE THE WOMEN WHO
WERE VICTIMIZED DURING WORLD
WAR TWO IN KOREA- MY CITY
GLENDALE WAS THE FIRST CITY ON
THE WEST COAST TO HAVE A
MONUMENT TO RECOGNIZE THE
KOREAN WOMEN AND THEIR
STRUGGLES. AND THE KOREAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HAS BEEN
STEADFAST AND RESOLUTE IN
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE WOMEN
WHO ARE BECOMING VOICELESS IS
MORE MORE OF THEM
UNFORTUNATELY- AND DIETS WERE
YOU KNOW MOVING THROUGH THE
GENERATIONS THAT THEIR VOICES
ARE HEARD AND THAT THEIR
MEMORY. IS REMEMBERED AND NOT
JUST FOR THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
AND YOUR HE NUYS THEIR OWN
PERSONAL STRUGGLES BUT TO ALSO
RAISE THE CONSCIOUSNESS OF THE
WORLD. THE STATE- WOMEN
INTEREST IN IN WAR AND HOW
WOMEN AND CHILDREN ARE. IN THE
VICTIMS OF CONFLICT AND MAKING
SURE THAT IN THEIR STORIES THAT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE
REMEMBERED AS WE MOVE THROUGH
OTHER ARMED CONFLICTS AND THAT
WE ALWAYS REMEMBER THAT WHILE.
PEOPLE GO TO WAR. OFTEN THOSE
THAT ARE LEFT AT HOME WHO
SUFFER THE MOST. SO AGAIN I
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR
ONE FORTY TWO I HOPE THAT ALL
OF YOU WILL JOIN US IN
RECOGNIZING- THIS ARE IMPORTANT
DAY AND THE MANY CONTRIBUTIONS
OF THE KOREAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER. THERE IS
FRIEDMAN MISTER PENA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FORTY TWO IN
AMERICAN DAY AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE CITY OF
RIVERSIDE. RIVERSIDE WAS HOME
TO DOES SIGN ON TRONG HOLE
LEADER OF KOREAN INDEPENDENCE
MOVEMENT. AND THE ORGANIZER OF
THE AMERICAN KOREAN COMMUNITY
RIVERSIDE WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
SETTLEMENTS OF KOREAN AMERICANS
IN THE UNITED STATES AND IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO IS MY
HONOR TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE
RESOLUTION AND URGE ALL TO VOTE
HI AND THIS IMPORTANT. OF
RESOLUTION THE REMINDS US OF
THE RICH HISTORY OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND OF THE UNITED
STATES. THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I ATE RICE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF A C. R. ONE
FORTY TWO AS A REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE SOUTH BAY AREA OF LOS
ANGELES WE CAN CONCLUDE
COMMUNITIES LIKE TORRANCE
GARDENA AND PALS BIRDIES
COMMUNITIES WITH LARGE CURRENT
AMERICAN POPULATIONS- I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION. I
ALSO RISE WELL AS THE ONLY
JAPANESE AMERICAN IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE I
THINK MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT-
THAT- THERE ARE MANY HISTORICAL
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE NATIONS
OF JAPAN AND SOUTH KOREA. BUT
HERE IN AMERICA. ALL AMERICANS
AND SO IN THAT SPIRIT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE FORTY TWO.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI
MISTER VOEPEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MISTER SPEAKER. I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE
FORTY TWO AS THE LAST VIETNAM
VETERAN. THAT WILL PROBABLY
SERVE IN THE ASSEMBLY IS NUMB
BEHIND ME THAT I CAN SEE. SO
LITTLE HISTORY LESSON. THE
KOREANS THE SOUTH KOREANS OR
ONE OF OUR GREATEST ALLIES NAY
HAVE PAID A PRICE FOR AMERICA.
A HEAVY PRICE. IN THE VIETNAM
WAR WHICH I'M FAMILIAR WITH
MORE THAN I'D LIKE TO THINK.
THE KOREANS LOST. FIVE THOUSAND
NINETY NINE KILLED IN ACTION.
THEY LOST TEN THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO WOUNDED
IN ACTION IT WAS THE GREATEST
BLOOD PRICE PAID BY ANY OF OUR
ALLIES IN VIETNAM. SO OUR
CASUALTIES WERE FIFTY EIGHT
THOUSAND. TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY KILLED IN ACTION. AND
THREE HUNDRED AND FOUR THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
WOUNDED IN ACTION. SO THE
KOREANS IN PROPORTION TO THEIR.
THE POPULATION PAID THE SAME
PRICE WE DID TO DEFEND FREEDOM.
AND COMBAT COMMUNISM CELL I
SIMPLY REMIND US BODY. THAT THE
KOREAN NATION SOUTH KOREA. OUR
GREAT HEROES AND GREAT
SUPPORTERS OF AMERICA AND THEY
BELIEVE IN LIFE LIBERTY AND THE
PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS EVEN
THOUGH WE MAY NEVER GET TO
HAPPINESS WE PURSUE IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS VOEPEL MINS
QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS TODAY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF A C. R. ONE FORTY
TWO AS A MEMBER THAT REPRESENTS
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY WITH A
GROWING KOREAN AMERICAN
POPULATION I TO NOT ONLY
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION
RESOLUTION BUT CONGRATULATE OUR
KOREAN FRIENDS WHO HAVE NOT
ONLY BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND SETTING UP
BUSINESSES. SETTING UP
DIFFERENT TYPE OF NON PROFITS
AND BEING OR NEIGHBORS THIS
FALL I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TRAVEL TO CARILLO TO SEOUL AND
YOUNG YEN AND WAS SO- AMAZED BY
THE BEAUTY OF THE COUNTRY BY
THE BEAUTY OF THE PEOPLE AND AS
WAS SAID WE HAVE MUCH THAT WE
HAVE WORKED ON TOGETHER WITH
OUR AMERICAN SOLDIERS STANDING
SIDE BY SIDE WELL OUR KOREAN.
OF FRIENDS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY WERE ABLE TO CONTINUE
THEIR FREEDOM AND SOUTH KOREA
MY FATHER ALL ACTUALLY WAS IN
THAT WAR- BUT AGAIN WE ARE
PROUD TO HAVE THEM AS OUR
FRIENDS OR NEIGHBORS IN OUR
BUSINESS- PARTNERS HERE AND
CALIFORNIA AND IN ORANGE
COUNTY. AND I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISS QUIRK
SILVA MISTER KANSEN CHU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I MISTER SPEAKER SO MEMBER ALSO
RISING STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
C. R. ONE FORTY TWO
REPRESENTING A HUGE NUMBER OF
KOREAN AMERICANS IN MY
DISTRICT. THERE IS- HUNDREDS OF
SMALL BUSINESS IN THE CITY OF
SANTA CLARA OF ALONG SIDE OF EL
CAMINO RIEL AND ALSO I HAD THE
HEAD QUARTER OFFICE AND SOME
AND HAND NEXT. IN THE NORTH
SELLS VERY AREA THAT NOT ONLY
CONTRIBUTING TO OUR INNOVATION
ECONOMY BUT ALSO- PROVIDE
THOUSANDS OR MARK TEN CELLS OF
THOUSANDS JOB TO OUR RESIDENTS
SO- CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE KOREAN
AMERICANS. CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
ECONOMY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHIU SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE RESOLUTION DOCTOR CHOI YOU
MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH. THANK
YOU SPEAKER AND ALL THE MEMBERS
AND THE WHOLE ROLE STOP BY- AND
THE SPOKE IN SUPPORT OF THIS-
RESOLUTION I AM REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT NOW WITH THAT
THE I WOULD LIKE TO OR SO I
HAVE THE HONORABLE INTRODUCED.
DOCTOR CHOI CHI CHI PAUSE YOU
WE WILL TAKE A VOTE AND THEN WE
WILL TRANSITION TO THE GAS
INTRODUCTION A DOCTOR WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION YES I DO. THANK YOU
DOCTOR CHOI WITH THAT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS MEMBERS THIS IS CO
AUTHORS. ON THE RESOLUTION THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. CO AUTHORS
AND ACR ONE FORTY TWO THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLE THERE ARE
SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
AND DOCTOR CHOI BACK TO YOU FOR
YOUR SPECIAL GUEST INTRODUCTION
OKAY THANK YOU TO BECOME ONCE
AGAIN AND MEMBERS SO FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IT IS- MY HONOR. TO
INTRODUCE THE YA OF FIRST TIME
IN THE REAR OF THE THIS
CHAMBER- OUR HONOR VOTER LAW
ONE JUNK HIM CONSUL GENERAL OF
THE REPUBLIC OF KOREA THE
STATION THE IN LOS ANGELES AND
ON ALSO ALL KINDS ON FROM THAT
SAME OFFICE OF MISTER K. ONE
COOL. JOINING WITH A- WITH US
ALSO ON THE GALLERY ARE
DISTINGUISH THE COMMUNITY
LEADERS OF THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. IN PARTICULAR- I WOULD
LIKE TO- ASK ALL EVERYBODY TO
RISE UP AND- YOU AB VIA AND US
AS SITE NAME- DON'T LEAD A THAT
THE REGIONAL LEADERS SO IT'S
OUR UNION GREW HE- FROM
SACRAMENTO REGION AND- HISTORY
IS PRESENT ABOVE GREEN AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION NOT SACRAMENTO AND
ATTENDING POPCORN FROM THE SAN
FRANCISCO AREA. AND THE GENIE
THE- FROM IS BAY AREA. AND ALSO.
NINETEENTH ACCORDION AMERICAN
THEY ARE AND THEN ALSO- I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK A ALL DAY-
INTERESTED IN- TAKING PICTURES
SO WITH ME AS I JOIN A PRESENT
THE RESOLUTION TO THE HONORABLE
OR- CONSULATE GENERAL OF LAW.
LOS ANGELES I CAME ONE SHOWING
IN THE RIO DE CHAMBER
. MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO THE CENTER
THIRD READING FILE. FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY TWO IS S. C. R.
THIRTY ONE. THE CLERK READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION%
THIRTY ONE BY SENATOR BRADFORD
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE
WILLIE L. BROWN JUNIOR CIRCLING
PLAZA. MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE
THIS KAMLAGER-DOVE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. S. C. R.
THIRTY ONE SEEKS TO HONOR
WILLIE L. BROWN JUNIOR BY
NAMING THE PUBLIC STREET CIRCLE
AND PLAZA AT NINE FOURTEEN AND
NINE FIFTEEN CAPITALMALL AS
THE WILLIE L. BROWN JUNIOR
CIRCLE IN PLAZA. MISTER BROWN
IS WIDELY REGARDED AS ONE OF
THE MOST INFLUENTIAL
POLITICIANS OF THE LATE
TWENTIETH CENTURY. AND HAS BEEN
AT THE CENTER OF CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT AND CIVIC LIFE FOR
AN ASTOUNDING FIVE DECADES. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY MISTER BROWN
MADE HISTORY WHEN HE BECAME THE
pOF THIS BODY A ROLE HE HELD FOR
A RECORD FIFTEEN YEARS.
ALTHOUGH I HEAR SOMEONE IS
CREEPING UP ON THAT. DURING HIS
THIRTY YEAR TENURE AS AN
ELECTED MEMBER OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY MISTER BROWN
LEFT HIS IMPRINT ON EVERY
ASPECT OF PUBLIC POLICY
IMPACTING THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SPECIFICALLY HIS
LEADERSHIP RESULTED IN
LEGISLATION THAT BANNED SEMI
AUTOMATIC WEAPONS GAINES STATE
DIVESTMENT FROM SOUTH AFRICA
AND CREATED STABILITY IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM THROUGH SCHOOL
FINANCE REFORM FOLLOWING HIS
MONUMENTAL ROLE AS SPEAKER OF
THE ASSEMBLY MISTER BROWN
CONTINUED HIS GROUND BREAKING
CAREER IN PUBLIC SERVICE AS THE
FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN MAYOR OF
SAN FRANCISCO WHERE HE SERVED
TWO TERMS. AS MAYOR MR BROWN
REFURBISHED AND REBUILD
CALIFORNIA'S BUSIEST TRANSIT
SYSTEM PIONEERED THE USE OF
BOND MEASURES TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND CREATED
A MODEL JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM
THESE ACCOMPLISHMENTS ARE JUST
A BRIEF GLIMPSE OF THE VARIETY
OF FORWARD THINKING POLICY
IDEAS THAT WERE FULLY REALIZED
UNDER BROWN'S LEADERSHIP. ESSIE
OUR THIRTY ONE CELEBRATES THOSE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AS WELL AS
MISTER BROWN'S UNRELENTING
DEDICATION TO A BETTER
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS CAM LONGER
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO
RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS- IN SUPPORT OF S. C. R.
THIRTY ONE DOUBLE READ THAT
WILL RENAME A STREET IN A PLAZA
TO THE WEST OF THE CAPITAL. OF
AFTER MISTER WILLIE BROWN. AS
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA BLACK
CAUCUS LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS
WE ARE HONORED TO BASICALLY
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION. FOR
MISTER BROWN BECAUSE OF HIS
LONGSTANDING COMMITMENT AND
DEDICATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND TO CALIFORNIA. THERE'S NO
ONE MORE FITTING FOR THIS
TRIBUTE TO GIVE OUT FOR US TO
GIVE TO AN INDIVIDUAL THAN TO
MISTER BROWN HIMSELF. WE KNOW
THAT THE BAY BRIDGE IS NAMED
AFTER HIM BUT THAT NEEDS TO BE
SOMETHING MUCH MORE TANGIBLE
AND VISIBLE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
SACRAMENTO AND THOSE WHO COME
TO VISIT THE CAPITAL. THEN TO
THE TO HAVE SOMETHING NAMED
AFTER MISTER BROWN. HIS TENURE
IN THIS LEGISLATURE OBVIOUSLY
IS LEGENDARY HE WILL HAVE THE
LONGEST HISTORY BASED ON OUR
LAWS AS THEY EXIST TODAY. THE
LONGEST HISTORY BEING THE IN
TERMS OF BEING THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN WHO NOT ONLY THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN BASICALLY
BEING THE SPEAKER OF THE
ASSEMBLY. THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN TO BASICALLY BE
SELECTED AS SPEAKER AND THERE'S
BEEN THREE AND HE'S BEEN ONE OF
THE THREE. THE INTERESTING
THING IS THAT MOST OF US KNOW
THAT- MISTER BROWN. WHO IS A
LONGTIME FRIEND OF MY FAMILY. I
KNEW HIM BEFORE HE WAS SPEAKER
AND HE WAS BRILLIANT AND HE
STILL IS BRILLIANT. HE'S A
MASTER POLITICIAN HE WAS NOT
ONLY A FRIEND TO DEMOCRATS BUT
HE WAS ALSO A FRIEND TO
REPUBLICANS. AND OFTEN SHOCKED
FOLKS WHEN HE COULD GET THINGS
DONE NOT ONLY WOULD DEMOCRATS
BUT WOULD REPUBLICANS. HE
ACTUALLY BECAME THE SPEAKER AS
A RESULT OF HIS LONG STANDING
RELATIONSHIP WITH REPUBLICANS
IN THIS HOUSE. AND SO WHEN YOU
LOOK AT HIM USED NOT ONLY SEE A
MAN WHO BASICALLY. RAN THIS
HOUSE BUT RAN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HE WAS SO POWERFUL
THAT THE ONLY WAY THEY COULD
GET HIM OUT OF OFFICE WAS TO
PASS A LAW TO LIMIT TERMS.
BECAUSE OTHERWISE HE WOULD
STILL BE HERE AS SPEAKER OF
THIS ASSEMBLY. HE WAS JUST THAT
POWERFUL OF AN INDIVIDUAL WHEN
YOU THOUGHT MET WILLIE BROWN HE
ALWAYS TALKED ABOUT THE FUTURE.
NOT WHAT WHAT'S BUT WHAT COULD
BE. AND PEOPLE IN THIS HOUSE%
ACTUALLY WERE SECURE IN KNOWING
THAT WHEN THINGS HAPPEN WILLIE
WOULD HANDLE IT. AND HE COULD
UP AND DOWN THE STATE HAMMER
THE ISSUE IS THAT WHAT BEFORE
SAYS. AS THE LEGISLATURE. WHEN
I WAS RUNNING FOR OFFICE IT WAS
INTERESTING THAT EVERY TIME I
TALK TO SOMEBODY. ABOUT WHAT
WAS HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA AND
HOW WE WERE IN CRISIS AND THEY
WOULD ALWAYS SAY BUT IT WILL IT
WAS THERE. IT WOULDN'T BE THAT
WAY. HE WOULD HAVE HANDLED IT
HE WOULD HAVE DONE THIS A DONE
THAT AND SO THAT WAS A HIGH
LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE IN HIS
LEADERSHIP NOT ONLY. IN TERMS
OF DEMOCRATS BUT ALSO IN TERMS
OF REPUBLICANS. HE WAS A BI
PARTISAN LEADER IN EVERY SENSE
OF THE WORD. A MAN WHO WAS A
MASTER AT POLITICS AND STILL IS
TO THIS DAY. WHEN I GET A CALL
IN IS FROM WILLIE BROWN I WAS
THE ALL MY GOD. WHAT NOW DOES
WILL THEY WANT AND HE STILL%
BASICALLY TRYING TO CHANGE AND
INFLUENCE LEGISLATION. AND
PEOPLE IN THIS HOUSE. WHILE
HE'S SITTING IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WE WOULD BE A BASICALLY HONOR
TO NAME A STREET AFTER WILLIE
BROWN. BECAUSE REALLY THIS IS A
MAN WHO STARTED FROM BASICALLY
VERY LITTLE. INTO IN TEXAS. AND
BET AND WORKED HIS WAY THROUGH
SCHOOL. WORK THIS WAY TO LAW
SCHOOL. BASICALLY CLIMBED UP TO
BECOME A LEGISLATOR. MADE
BASICALLY FALSE UNHAPPY
SOMETIMES OF THE DECISIONS THAT
HE MADE. AND SHOCKED CALIFORNIA
WHEN HE BECAME THE SPEAKER.
SHOCKED CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF
HOW HE BECAME SPEAKER WHILE
THEY WERE FIGHTING ABOUT
SOMETHING ELSE. WILLIE WAS
WORKING HIS AGENDA. AND HE
BECAME SPEAKER OF THIS HOUSE
AND HE RAN THIS HOUSE ITH SOME
DIGNITY AND FOCUS AND
CALIFORNIA WAS STRONGER AND WE
WILL BE STRONGER. AS A RESULT
OF ALL THE THINGS HE'S DONE SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. SB ARE THIRTY ONE. THE
NAME OF THE STREET AFTER BROWN
A LEADER WHO STARTED THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS. WHO STARTED BAY PACKED
THE BLACK AMERICAN POLITICAL
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
ONE OF THE A. FOUNDERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF.
GLORIOUS HE HAS BASICALLY MADE
STATE A POWERFUL STATE I WAS
YES SUPPORT. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER YOUR COOLEY RECKON. WHAT
COLLEAGUES I'M JUST THRILLED
AND IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THINKING BACK TO THE TIME WHEN
HE BECAME SPEAKER EARLY IN MY
CAREER I LIVED IN THAT AARON SO
THREE THINGS ARE JUST BUILT
ABOUT WILLIE BROWN. ON HOW FAR
HE TRAVELED IN HIS LIFE.
BECAUSE I REMEMBER THE TIMES
WHEN YOU HEAR WILLIE BROWN TELL
THE STORY GROWING UP A CHILD IN
BROWNSVILLE TEXAS. WHERE HE
WOULD. TO MAKE ENDS MEET HE
WOULD SHINE SHOES. AND IT WOULD
TELL THE STORY OF THE LITTLE.
BLACK BOY IN BROWNSVILLE TEXAS
NEW CHINA ISSUES FOR THE
RANCHERS AND THEN THEY WOULD
THROW HIS PAYMENT IN THIS
PLATOON. TO FOR SOME ON HIM THE
INDIGNITY OF FISHING IS PAYMENT
OUT OF ALL OF THAT IN THIS BOOK
TO. AND SO YOU KNOW. JOKES ON
THEM HOW FAR WILLIE BROWN WENT
FROM BROWNSVILLE TEXAS I ALSO
WANT TO KNOW TO JUST FOR THE
MEMBERS HERE REFLECT UPON THIS
LITTLE CIRCLE ACROSS THE STREET
TO HONOR WILLIE BROWN THERE IS
ACTUALLY NO PLACE IN ALL OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT CONVEYS THE
CENTER OF STATE GOVERNMENT. THE
WAY TENTH AND WILLIE BROWN
JUNIOR CIRCLE CONVEYS IT.
DECADES OF PLANNING PROTECTED
NOT CAPITOL MALL OUT OF THE
TOWER BRIDGE THE LIBRARY OF
COURSE BUILDING ON REBUILDING
THE STATE CAPITAL THERE IS NO
SPOT THE SUPERFINAL
PERSONIFIES. THIS SITE OF
CALIFORNIA GOVERNORS A SPOT
WHICH WE NOW HONOR WILLIE AT.
IN ON THIS FINAL NOTE THE BOTH
MY COLLEAGUES EMPHASIZE THE
COLLEGIALITY. YOU KNOW WHAT AN
ERROR HE HAD BEEN A MEMBER FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS. WHEN IT BECAME
SPEAKER FOR FIFTEEN YEARS HE
HAD A UNPARALLELED QUALITY
RELATIONSHIPS AROUND THE BODY
WHICH IS VERY. AND MONITORING
TO ALL OF US. BUT IT THIS
EXAMPLEOF COLLEGIALITY AND THE
IMPACT HE HAD WHEN LOMA PRIETA
HIT. IN OCTOBER OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE AND ARE FREEWAYS
STARTED FALLING DOWN. SPEAKER
WILLIE L. BROWN WITH KEN MADDY
THE MINORITY LEADER. TAKING
STOCK OF WHAT HAD HIT
CALIFORNIA. DID A HANDSHAKE
DEAL. THAT WE SHOULD JUST ADOPT
THE ROUTE OF A SALES TAX FOR A
LIMITED PERIOD OF TIME TO RAISE
FUNDS RAPIDLY FOR THE
REBUILDING OF CALIFORNIA AND
HAVING STRUCK A HANDSHAKE DEAL
WITH THE MINORITY LEADER IN THE
SENATE. IT WAS QUICKLY EXECUTE.
AND I THINK SO IT HONORS
WILLING TO KIND OF SAY THAT WAS
A CHOLERA READERSHIP HE HAS.
BUT THAT TOO IS A MONITORING OF
ALL OF US THE POWER. OF SERVING
AS A MEMBER OF THE LEGISLATURE.
THE ABILITY OF COLLEAGUES TO
BEND THE CURVE IN THE FUTURE
WHEN NECESSARY BY CONCERTED
ACTION WILLIE CERTAINLY
EXEMPLIFIES THAT. BUT IS NOT
JUST A THING TO BE HONORED WITH
SORT OF A GUY POST AND OUR OWN
LIVES SO GREAT TO HAVE THAT
CIRCLE IN HONOR OF HIM GINGIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS COOLEY SAYING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. ON THE RESOLUTION
MS CAM WATER YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUES MISTER COOLEY AND
DOCTOR WEBER. FOR SHARING BOTH
THEIR COMMENTS AND A BRIEF
HISTORY LESSON ON- THE DYNAMIC
NATURE. OF WILLIE BROWN AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AND
SEE OUR THIRTY ONE. IN MS CAM
WATER WOULD YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS
ON YES MISSION. FIRST ROLE WE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS MEMBERS FOR
CLUB THERE ALL. NUMBER SYSTEMS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON AND SEE OUR
THIRTY ONE THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. THIS
FOR CO AUTHORS. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS QUIRK WELL. CLOSER
AUTHOR SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS
ADDED ON THE RESOLUTION WE WILL
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON THIS
SG J. R. CAR CLUB THEY'RE ALL.
ALL MEMBERS. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSER ROLE. I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO. THAT
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. FILE
ITEMS ONE THIRTY THREE AND ONE
THIRTY FOUR PASS RETAIN.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE MOVE TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY SOME
BRIEF ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS
TOMORROW IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER IS BIRTHDAY PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WISHING HIM A HAPPY
BIRTHDAY. AND KATE WILL BE
SERVED TOMORROW IN THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OFFICE WHICH IS ROOM
TWENTY ONE SEVENTEEN FROM ONE
THIRTY TO THREE PM SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
JANUARY FOURTEENTH CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY JANUARY
FIFTEENTH CHECK N SESSION.
THURSDAY JANUARY SIXTEENTH
CHECK IN SESSION AND FRIDAY
JANUARY SEVENTEENTH FLOOR
SESSION. IS AT NINE AM IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED GERMAN TO MEMORY. AND
ALSO MEMBERS WITHOUT IT IN A
QUORUM CALL IS LEFT IN. THE
REMAINING MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS. FOR GERMANS TO
MEMORY SO WE MAY GIVE ARE A
SPECK FULL ATTENTION YOUR
COLLEAGUES MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR
. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
MEMORY. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF MY GOOD FRIEND OF MINE
THOUGH GONZALEZ COMBINE. I'D
MONDO GONZALEZ GOVIND PASSED
AWAY ON DECEMBER TWENTY EIGHTH.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
SURROUNDED BY HIS DAUGHTER AND
SON. AT THE STANFORD HOSPITAL
IN PALO ALTO CALIFORNIA HE WAS
SEVENTY ONE YEARS OLD. I'D
MONDAY WAS BORN IMPORTER RICO
AND RECEIVED HIS BACHELOR'S AND
MASTER'S DEGREE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF PORTER RICO AND
HIS PHD DEGREE FROM CORNELL
UNIVERSITY. I'D MONDO HAD BEEN
A RESIDENT OF RIVERSIDE SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHTY AND
WORKED AS A RESEARCH ECONOMIST
AT THE US FOREST SERVICE
PACIFIC SOUTHWEST RESEARCH
STATION WHERE HE CONDUCTED
RESEARCH ON THE ECONOMIC OF
FACTS OF WILD LAND FIRES ON
NATURAL RESOURCES. AND ALSO
PUBLISHED NUMEROUS SCIENTIFIC
ARTICLES. OUR MONDO SERVICE
CONSULTANT ON THE FOREST
SERVICE AND THE AGENCY FOR
INTERNATIONAL DEVELOPMENT
SPONSORED MISSIONS TO ARGENTINA
CHILE COSTA RICA ECUADOR GHANA
HONDURAS MEXICO. BETTER AND
SPAIN I'D MIND THOSE TEACHING
pEXPERIENCE INCLUDED TEACHING AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF PORTER RICO
THE NEW HAMPSHIRE COLLEGE
PORTER RICO CAMPUS AND VISITING
PROFESSOR OF ENVIRONMENTAL
ECONOMICS AT UC RIVERSIDE AND
VISITING PROFESSOR OF NATURAL
RESOURCE ECONOMICS AT THE
INTERNATIONAL UNIVERSITY OF ON
THE LUCIUS SPAIN. ARE MONDO
RECEIVED NUMEROUS LOCAL AND
INTERNATIONAL AWARDS AND
RECOGNITIONS IT WAS THE TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN BUT THE FLAG
GOES INTERNET AWARD RECIPIENT.
AGREED SPAIN CIVIL RIGHTS AND
RECEIVE THE PRESTIGIOUS
PRESIDENT'S CALL TO SERVICE
AWARD IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
PRESERVES VOLUNTEER
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CONCEIVE YOUR
FOR THE SPANISH SPEAKING AT THE
CENTER OF THE NEWS AND
RIVERSIDE. ARE MONDO SURVIVED
BY HIS BELOVED DAUGHTER NICOLE
HIS SON IN LAW RYAN PATTERSON
HIS BELOVED SON OMAR AND
DAUGHTERS LILA RAO AND HIS
THREE GRAND THERE'S I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY ABOUT
MULTIPLE GONZALEZ GO BY. THANK
YOU MISTER MEDINA. MS
PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR SHERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY WITH A HEAVY HEART
TO ADJOURN AND THE MEMORY OF
WILLIAM WILL AT JUNIOR WILLIAM
WHO WE LOVINGLY NO IT'S BELL
WAS A DECORATED KOREAN WAR
VETERAN AND HAD A LONG AND
ACCOMPLISHED CAREER AS THE CITY
MANAGER OF FOR CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF ORANGE COUNTY'S
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR
AGENCIES IN NINETEEN FIFTY TWO
BILLS SERVED AS A FIRST
LIEUTENANT THE US ARMY AIR
INFANTRY DURING THE CURRENT
WAR. AMONG HIS MILITARY
DECORATIONS BILL WAS AWARDED A
SILVER STAR NATIONAL DEFENSE
SERVICE MEDAL AND PURPLE HEART
AT THE AGE OF TWENTY NINE BILL
BEGAN HIS CAREER AS THE MANAGER
OF ROSE MADE HE LATER SERVED IN
THIS ROLE FOR TEMPLE CITY AND
THEN MONTEREY PARK HE
EVENTUALLY BECAME THE VERY
FIRST CITY MANAGER IN IRVINE
RESEARCH FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO THROUGH NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE. BILL PLAYED A VITAL ROLE
IN THE SUCCESS OF THE CITY OF
IRVINE AND PLAYED KEY
LEADERSHIP ROLES IN THE
CREATION OF THE IRVINE POLICE
DEPARTMENT THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
MINE'S NOT ONLY CLAIM TO PARK
SYSTEM OPENING AT THE CIVIC
CENTER AND HE ALSO OVERSAW THE
STRUCTURE OF THE HERITAGE PARK
X. X. WE- NOW. HIS NAME.
ASSEMBLY CHECK SEVENTY FOUR HAS
LOST A WONDERFUL PUBLIC SERVANT
WHO LEFT HIS FAMILY AND LOVED
OUR COMMUNITY. OUR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS GO OUT TO BILLS FAMILY
OF FOUR CHILDREN AND HIS WIFE
BETTY JO. HE WILL BE DEEPLY
MISSED AND FONDLY REMEMBERED I
ASK YOU TO JOIN ME TODAY IN IN
TRAINING IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISS PETRIE-NORRIS AND
DOCTOR CHOI YOUR ALSO
RECOGNIZED ON THIS A GERMAN.
THANK YOU SPEAKER. I ALSO RISE
SO IN MEMORY OF. WILLIAM OR LET
THE WHO SERVED AS A FIRST. CITY
MANAGER OF A CITY OF IRVINE THE
CITY THAT I ALSO SHARE WITH THE
MEMBER OF BETWEEN NORRIS.
MEMBERS SOME MISTO WILLIAM
WOULD LET WHAT BILL WAS AN
AMAZING MAN WITH SO MUCH
RESPECTED THE- AND THEN ALSO I
HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO GET TO
KNOW HIM EVEN GOAL. I DO NOT
THE- CHANCE TO WORK SIDE BY
SIDE WHEN I JOIN THE CITY
COUNCIL. BUT THE HE IS A WELL
REMEMBERED AND THEN ALSO- HIS-
VARY HE HAS BEEN VERY VERY
ACTIVE. IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION. BECAUSE ALL
FOR HIS INVOLVEMENT IN THE-
CITY ARE NOT ONLY A CITY- WIDE
ACTIVITY IS THAT AND THEN ALSO-
FOR THE VETERANS OF COMMUNITY I
DON'T WANT THE NAME HEY MASS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THE YEAR. BUT
THE HE RESPECTIVELY- DECLINED
WHEN HE WAS IN THE HOSPITAL
SAYING THAT THERE ARE MANY I
TELL YOUNG PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
GIVE THAT ON A TOWARD THE
PEOPLE NOT MUCH TO HIS SOUL
NUMBER THE- PERSON. PASSED
AWAY- DECIDE LAST NOVEMBER-
FROM COMPLICATIONS OF A PARK
USES DISEASE. WHILE HE WAS ON
ON ON THE- STARTING UP A CITIES
SO WHAT IS THE ABOLITION PARKS
TO WAR- A TO A DELIVERY CENTERS
HE WAS A SPENDING TIME WITH
HIS. KIDS SAID AND ALSO GRAND
CHILDREN. FOR THAT THE HIS CELL
OR SOLD VERY WELL LOVE THE-
GRANDPA AND UP PARENTS. THERE
WAS A ONE OF THOSE SO RARE
INDIVIDUALS THAT THE TRULY MADE
YOU FEEL LIKE- YOU HAVE KNOWN
HIM UP FOR A LONG TIME AS A
FRIEND A RESPECTABLE YEARS-
SUPPORT THE AND THE MASS THAT
THE WE ARE JOINED THIS A MEMORY
OF A DISCUSSION IN MEMORY OF
APPEAL. THANK YOU. THANK CHECK
CHOI. DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE- DEEPLY SADDENED BY THE
RECENT PASSING OF DR CAROL
WAYMAN IS SAN DIEGO CIVIL
RIGHTS HERO CONSTITUENTS FRIEND
AND COLLEAGUE. DR KERR A WOMAN
WAS BORN MAY FIFTEENTH NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE TO JOHN DEVINE IN
MERRICK KATE WOMEN IN TAIWAN
NORTH CAROLINA. AND RECENTLY
PASSED AWAY OBVIOUSLY AT THE
AGE OF NINETY FOUR. I MET KERR
AWAY MEN AND NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO AND I WAS MOST IMPRESSED
ONCE BECAUSE HIS MOTHER HIS
SISTER IS NINA SIMONE. AND I
WAS IMPRESSED BY HER COMING TO
SAN DIEGO TO MEET WITH HER
BROTHER. I LITTLE DIDN'T KNOW
MUCH AT THE TIME OF HIS HISTORY
AND HIS DEPTH OF COMMITMENT TO
SAN DIEGO. IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FOUR WHEN HE WAS WORKING ON
RACIAL ISSUES FOR THE LOS
ANGELES RIGHT REYES HUMAN
RELATIONS AGENCY. HE WAS CALLED
TO SAN DIEGO AND ASKED TO LOOK
AT OUR SYSTEM AND TO TELL US
WHAT WE WERE MISSING AND WHAT
THE ISSUES WERE IN TERMS OF
RACE IN SAN DIEGO. HE STE HE
SCRATCHED HIS HEAD HE SAID
BECAUSE IT WAS SOLD DEEP IN SO
MUCH HE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
SO I TOLD THEM THAT YEAH WE
HAVE A PROBLEM IN OUR BIGGEST
PROBLEM IS THAT WE DON'T KNOW
THAT WE HAVE A PROBLEM. SOON
AFTER THAT HE WAS APPOINTED TO
HE WAS INVITED TO RETURN TO SAN
DIEGO TO LIVE. AND TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE ON RACIAL ISSUES IN
SAN DIEGO. HE WAS APPOINTED THE
HEAD OF THE CITIZENS IN A
RACIAL COMMITTEE. WHERE IT WAS
WHERE HE BECAME THE FIRST HUMAN
RELATIONS AGENCY CHARGED WITH
CONVENING COMMUNITY DIALOGUES.
IDENTIFYING RACIAL INJUSTICE
AND EDUCATING THE PUBLIC ABOUT
RACIAL TENSIONS IN SAN DIEGO.
HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
NULLIFYING RESTRICTIVE
COVENANTS SO THAT AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND OTHER PEOPLE OF
COLOR COULD LIVE ANYWHERE THEY
WANTED IN SAN DIEGO. HE WROTE
THE FIRST EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
ORDINANCE FOR THE CITY AND THE
COUNTY WHICH OPEN UP
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EMPLOYMENT
FOR EVERYONE. HE ALSO PLAYED A
MAJOR ROLE IN MAKING IT
POSSIBLE FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
TO STAY IN ANY OF THE MAJOR
HOTELS IN THE COUNTY. AND MADE
IT POSSIBLE FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS TO BE ABLE TO TRY ON
CLOTHES BELIEVE IT OR NOT IN
DEPARTMENT STORES AND DINE IN
THE MAJOR RESTAURANTS IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES. ONE OF HIS
MOST CHALLENGING IT ACTUALLY
WAS HOWEVER WAS IN EDUCATION.
DR WAYMAN WAS A RETIRED
EDUCATOR AND HE WAS A CO
FOUNDER OF THE AFRICANA STUDIES
DEPARTMENT. WHEN I CAME TO SAN
DIEGO HE WAS ALREADY THERE
TEACHING CLASSES AND TRYING THE
BEST HE COULD TO ESTABLISH AN
AFRICANA STUDIES DEPARTMENT. HE
WAS DILIGENT AND HARD WORKING
AND WORKED IN AFRICA STUDIES AS
WELL AS THE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION
ALWAYS TRYING TO OPEN UP
OPPORTUNITIES. AND TO DEAL WITH
THE RACIAL BARRIERS THAT
EXISTED. WHEN THE AFRICAN
REFUGEES CAME TO SAN DIEGO IN
THE NINETEEN NINETIES. CAROL
WAYMAN WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
PERSONS TO WELCOME THEM TO SAN
DIEGO. HE KNEW WHAT IT WAS LIKE
TO BE DIFFERENT IN THE FEEL
DIFFERENT. AND AS A RESULT HE
FORMED A COALITION BETWEEN THE
AFRICAN REFUGEES IN AFRICAN
AMERICANS FOR US TO TEACH THEM
ABOUT AMERICAN WAYS AND
TRADITIONS THAT THEY DIDN'T
KNOW. ABOUT IN ORDER TO- THEY
WOULDN'T FEEL EMBARRASSED WHEN
THEY WENT PUBLIC AND DID THINGS
THAT WERE CONSIDERED
UNACCEPTABLE. HE'S BEEN OVER
FIFTY YEARS GIVING OF HIMSELF.
AND HELPING SAN DIEGO BREAK BE
AREAS. AND BECOMING A MORE
TOLERANT EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
CITY. HE RECEIVED NUMEROUS
AWARDS. IN ADDITION TO HIS
LOCAL HERO WHERE HE WAS GIVEN
BY THE TAKE THE BY KPBS. HE IS
A RECIPIENT OF THE SOMALI
YOUTH. A UNITED COMMUNITY AWARD
THE FIRST WHEN THEY GAVE. AND
LAST YEAR HE WAS A JACKIE
ROBINSON DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR DIGNITY HONOREE.
CALLAWAY MINUTES DURING HIS
HISTORY IN TIME AS AS A
PROFESSOR AND HISTORIAN KEPT
COPIOUS NOTES AND RECORDS. AND
SO ABOUT A YEAR AGO HE MADE
KNOWN THE FACT THAT HE HAD OVER
A HUNDRED BOXES OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN DOCUMENTS LETTERS
PICTURES PROGRAMS ALL DEALING
WITH THE ISSUE OF RACE IN SAN
DIEGO AND DOCUMENTING A RACIAL
ARE IN A RACIAL COMMITTEES. HE
HAD TREMENDOUS PHOTOGRAPHS AND
THINGS THAT WOULD JUST AMAZING
THE DOCUMENT AT THE FIFTY YEAR
HISTORY THAT HE HAD IN SAN
DIEGO. HE WAS GOING TO
BASICALLY TAKE THIS TREASURER
HIMSELF AND TRY TO DO SOMETHING
WITH THE ALSO WROTE A BOOK ON
BEING BLACK IN SAN DIEGO. WHAT
WAS INTERESTING HE WAS TRYING
TO DO THAT BUT HE HAD OBVIOUSLY
HAD SO MUCH YOU COULD NOT AND
FORTUNATELY WE WERE ABLE TO
PERSUADE HIM TO DONATE IT TO
THESAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY
LIBRARY. WHICHIS THE LARGEST
COLLECTION THEY'VE EVER
RECEIVED FROM ANY INDIVIDUAL.
CAL WHEN WAS AN AMAZING PERSON.
HE WAS ALWAYS INVOLVED AND IN
THINKING CONSTANTLY ABOUT WHAT
HE COULD DO TO CHANGE
RELATIONSHIPS AND IMPROVE THE
RACE RELATIONS IN SAN DIEGO.
MANDELA SAID DEFICIT SOMETHING
THAT IS INEVITABLE THE WHEN A
MAN HAS DONE WHAT HE CONSIDERS
TO BE HIS DUTY TO HIS PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY HE CAN REST IN
PLEASE. HE'S I BELIEVEMANDELA
DSA OF THAT I HAVE MADE THAT
EFFORT AND THAT IS THERE FOR Y.
SLEEP WITH THE AND WITH
ETERNITY. I THINK WE CAN SAY
THE SAME THINGWITH DOCTOR CARE
WAYMENT HE WAS SURELY REST IN
PEACE WITH THE ANCESTORS
BECAUSE HE HASDONE HIS DUTY
FOR HIS PEOPLE AND HIS COUNTRY
AND IRESPECTFULLY ASK THE WE-
ARE JOINED IN MEMORY OF DOCTOR
CARE A WOMAN. YOU DOCTOR WEBER
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NEXT
NAMES TO THE DESK TO BE PRINTED
THE JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS WHICH
ARE IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED. SEEN
HERE NOW FOR THE BUSINESS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN MISTER COOLEY MOVES AND
MISTER MEDINA SECONDS. THAT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL FRIDAY JANUARY
SEVENTEENTH. AT NINE AM WE ARE
ADJOURNED